the Global Agenda councils offer a
really powerful opportunity to capture
the innovation and knowledge of the
private sector we have global
institutions for governance the United
Nations is has been in this role for
decades now and while many would
question whether it's doing its job
there is clearly a need for to
complement that role with a more
powerful voice for the private sector
and these Global Agenda councils can
really harness the comparative advantage
of the private sector the understanding
of innovation the power of revenue
models for sustainability and really set
up the world for positive change